the jurgen experience
comedians don't and really can't
exercise political power they might you
know influence to a certain extent the
way that people think about certain
things
but
um
nobody's
you know nobody who's who's doing comedy
is uh is making decisions you know that
that directly uh directly impact
uh people's lives so so if if you were
actually trying
to to do that you know like if you're
actually trying to affect real change
this doesn't make any sense what i think
it is is it's a symptom
of how extreme this kind of moralistic
approach to politics
can get right that like you're this
concerned with like constantly
you know testing you know whether
somebody is a is a good person or a bad
person or they ever said anything that
you know that might show them to like to
really be a bad person and nothing could
ever just be a bad moment right that you
know that that it has to be like this is
the moment where you really revealed the
you know how toxic your soul was or
something you know rather than just like
you said something stupid because
sometimes people say things that are
stupid you know that uh
like i think that that kind of moralism
when it's applied to comedy
i think that that's i think that that's
like maybe the most extreme symptom of
of what i'm talking about because it's
one thing even to get mad at somebody
because like
of something they wrote like in an
editorial right that they're they're
telling you like exactly what they think
should happen you know that like if i
you know if i write you know if i write
something for jacobin and you know some
people get upset about that okay at
least it's jack of an article i'm
literally saying exactly what i think
right but
if you're doing you know a um
account like so so that last uh dave
dave chappelle special at netflix you
know that people people got mad about
and which by the way i you know hadn't
even watched but since i had ridden this
thing you know people kept asking me
what i thought and i finally watched it
and i thought that the way that it was
portrayed as if it were this like
just festival of transphobic you know
hatred preposterous was ridiculous that
in fact
the overall theme of the special as far
as those issues go was about him like
moving towards a place of greater
understanding and you know and like and
it's also kind of a love letter to his
friend that committed suicide for
supporting him was attacked for
supporting him and then she
jumped off a [ __ ] building and
committed suicide this is like an an
homage to this person's life this long
part of like i worked with dave during
the entire time he was piecing that
together because we started doing shows
in austin
like uh
november of 2020 i mean it might have
even been earlier than that and we were
working together while he was putting it
together and he was
responding to this idea that he was
transphobic
and he was saying like this is so crazy
like this is who i am and this is about
this person who when i was accused of
being transphobic this person defended
me and was dragged by people
and there's been some talk of whether or
not like how much of that was creative
license because like people have tried
to find like what the tweets were
how many of them were dms like we don't
know i mean i don't think you could
dismiss that or how many of them
or people who actually knew her
personally but then committed suicide
and like this is like trying to make
it's the highest form of comedy in a lot
of ways because you're trying to take
this like
socially sensitive issue and extract
laughs from it which is very difficult
to do but in no way was it transphobic
in no way was it hurtful or cruel or or
mean well i mean i mean actually he's
like he spent a couple minutes of the
special explaining why the bathroom laws
in north carolina were cruel
and like at the end like when he's
talking about his dead friend
like one of the crucial moments comes
when he's describing their like back and
forth you know when he he had her open
for him and yeah and it's hilarious yeah
which is a hilarious thing but there is
this like really moving part of it right
at the at the end where you know he you
know she she tells him you know like
uh i want you to recognize that i'm
going through a real humid experience
and like it really sinks in that and the
idea that watching this would make
somebody more transphobic yeah just just
seems absurd to me but what people did
right is
they literally quoted individual
sentences that he says in it like like
there's one point in the special where
he says
uh i'm a turf right turf standing for
transition
radical
yeah it's like okay but
literally within like two minutes of him
saying i'm on team turf he says
i'm not saying that i don't think trans
women are women it's like well hold on
right like you know if if you take both
of those literally right those those two
those two don't go together right but of
course that's not how comedy works
that's like thinking that like somebody
who writes a novel that like every
sentence of the novel is like what they
actually personally think is is true
but i think and i've got to think that a
lot of people who write articles like
this
must understand that on some level right
that they that like this is not how
comedy works but i think that
you know sometimes it's like bad faith
they're you know they're just being
dishonest definitely some of that but
like also i think that
like sometimes if you get this invested
in like
making these like moral indictments of
people over these culture war battles
then
you're just not even pausing to think
about that like you're just like trying
to find evidence like you're just like
like sifting through it to like find
like it's like uh you know freddie
deboer the commentator
no okay so freddie deboer is a is a
writer he wrote a really good book
about the education system called call
to smart
and he has this essay from a few years
ago called planet of cops uh where he
says
that it seems to him that like
increasingly
everybody you know in the culture is is
a is a cop now right what he means by
that and you know he develops the
metaphor he says things like
you know oh there's the new movie that
people are getting excited about you
know well give me you know give me two
hours and 500 words and i'll find you
your indictments right you know that
it's it's like that's sort of constantly
sifting through things to like find
evidence that people have have committed
some kind of
sin or or or infraction
and and i think that like that's how
people are approaching that like when
they wrote these
articles you know about you know how
oh my god did you know that dave
chappelle said that he was on team turf
you know
that's special
like look there's a mission right you
know you gotta you gotta get those
indictments right so you just have to
sort through all all of it until you can
find something that you know that looks
like a
a smoking gun
of of evidence and and i think that it's
like it's a obviously it's a terrible
way to write about anything but i think
what what's interesting to me about the
example of comedy
is that
it's sort of the most absurd possible
application
of of doing that
because i mean just just to be like
simplistic about it for a second right
like if you're saying something to stand
up special
like generally speaking not every
sentence but like you're saying it
because you think it's funny right
that's which is just a different thing
from saying something because like oh
you know here is exactly what i think
right you know it's like the example
that we were talking about before the
podcast which i'm not going to do
because it's actually in my act now
that someone put a quote that i said oh
yeah
what a piece of [ __ ] i and i'm like hey
you got to put the whole quote there's
like a lot more to that and it's clearly
joking but it's that
thing that they do
is also because someone is getting a
disproportionate and exorbitant amount
of attention and when someone is like a
dave chappelle or myself who's
got a disproportionate amount of
attention there's so many people that
want to look at that and go flaws holes
peppa keg throw rocks like and it's a
normal thing to
have this sort of uh reaction
to someone who you feel either their
take on things isn't valid or it's not
this it doesn't align with your own or
you there's a reason why you're more
morally superior to them because your
position is better
you know
yeah no i think there i think there's a
lot of that you know and and it's also i
mean it kind of goes back to we're
saying earlier about the uh the
you know blm protests and the aftermath
and all that stuff
like
if you get somebody like if um i mean
obviously in a case as high profile it's
like dave chappelle like netflix isn't
going to dump him because like why would
they do that like that would just be
putting like a lot of money on the uh
well not only that but there's no reason
to right here's the thing it's like if
dave chappelle was saying all trans
people would die should die and you know
we they're not human
okay yeah get rid of them right
everybody would agree to that you
shouldn't put that on your network but
you cannot look at any of the things
that he said and rationalize any of
these accusations that people have
towards them he is not that guy he's a
lovely guy if you meet him he's one of
the kindest nicest sweetest guys
that's who he really is and it's really
striking too because if you remember
when all this was going on
there was like a week of the news that
was all about how there's gonna be this
huge walkout of trans employees at
netflix remember this yeah they took
like a lunch break
it was like five of them yeah there were
like five people and it's not even clear
that they all worked at netflix oh most
of them didn't and then the one of them
that was there they found a whole bunch
of racist [ __ ] that she had put on
twitter and they're like hey
and then not even jokes just like racist
stuff it's like
god damn it i don't i get what's going
on these are like they're humans humans
are flawed and you know just because
they said a thing that was incorrect
doesn't mean that they're
whatever position they have they can't
have a good perspective on something
yeah and what and what kills me about
that example is at that very moment that
that was going on right that there was
this like
super hyped up you know walk out that
like got all this attention there was
like you know two people on their lunch
break or whatever like at the same time
there was the john deere strike going on
and that was that was you know
thousands of people you know were were
out on strike
for uh to you know to get better you
know wages and working conditions
john deere the tractors yeah yep yep the
the workers
yeah yeah if you go um
if you go i believe you but i mean yeah
i never heard a peep out of that yeah
well that's the thing right so like you
compare the scale of the two things and
then you compare the scale of the
coverage right one of them is jokes but
it's also jokes from the greatest living
comedian that's part of the problem it's
like you and also a guy who you uh you
sort of associate with left-wing values
and progressive values and you want them
to fall in line and i think that's part
of the blowback
is that you know they they want to shame
him into falling in line with their
ideals and one of the things that he
said like when he we talked about the
special and we this was we did a show
together and he did this speech at an
arena
and he's like like i am not going to
comply
with the way you you know want me to
think and want me to behave that's not
what i'm doing
yeah
and again like what's his response gonna
be realistically like he's he's just
gonna um keep talking [ __ ] that's what
he's gonna do right i mean it's gonna be
funnier and funnier right you know but
like he like the idea that like saying
like he's a terrible person he's a
transphobe like is gonna get him to like
see things more from your perspective in
fact he talks about this in the special
right that like he
you know he has the thing about the
woman who like followed him out to the
parking lot or whatever to you know to
give him a hard time
and
the point is that like all of that like
his reaction was just [ __ ] you right you
know like of course it is right you know
but like
then like actually meeting this trans
woman and like having this you know like
like you know like you know having the
interactions that they had and like
having that mean something to him right
like that that um
like that did way more probably to get
him to see things the way that people
were yelling at him wanted him to see
them then like
people just like saying you know that
like because if you say like if somebody
wants to like shut you down or silence
you or like berate you until you you
know you stop thinking what you think
then i i mean
maybe like if somebody's powerless
enough they'll just shut up because they
don't want to deal with it right you
know but like otherwise
like one thing it's not gonna do
is to get them to say okay now i see
you're right right especially they might
say their perceptions they might say the
words if they think they have to right
but they're not going to think it right